hello everyone this next game is also
brought to you as a suggestion from from
one of the subscribers and he just wrote
that I should do a game back off slicer
and well I decided to do so since he was
a pretty strong player he was an
Austrian chess master and a theoretician
and well although this game is played in
1899 in nineteen and ten he almost
became world champion as he played the
World Championship match against Emanuel
Lasker and it was it was a very tight
match the match ended five to five I
think it was a it was a both of them had
one win and eight draws but selector
actually had a winning position in the
last game they played but then he
blundered the position into a draw and
then he blundered again into a losing
position so yeah a very unfortunate
event for color selector but you know
Emanuel Esper was an extremely strong
guy he did hold the world championship
title for 27 years but this game is not
against Emanuel after this game is
against Felix Meeker
like I said played in 1899 and it was it
was one of the more interesting games I
could find by play by college selector
so let's hit against Leiter is the
flatterers white and the Civic McNary's
black we have E for and yet featuring a
very very interesting variation in the
Italian game e5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 the Italian
game c3 Knight to f6 we have d 4e
captures on d4 seek answers on d4 and
Bishop to b4 check and now select
replace and Knight to c3 inviting black
to go for the Greco attack
I mean to allow White's to go for the
Greco attack so Philip does he plays a
nice captures on e4 and flustered
castles and well it's obvious that the
blacks can win a pawn here if Beck's
would play something like Knight
captures on c3 be captures on c3 and
Bishop captures on c3 then this will be
the main line of the Greco attack and no
one well who knows
waitress would ever because that's
playing this with the black pieces as
white can play here Queen to b3 now
attacking this Bishop and c3 and also
the f7 pawn and if the work is captured
simply Bishop captures and f7 Check Into
f8 Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen so
only move would be
Knight to e7 and then rook to e1 and
this as well
impossible to play for black is
completely winning for white so after
selector castled meet nerd decided to
play Bishop captures on c3 but this is
also kind of kind of a line of the Greco
attack we have a d5 now nice to e5 and
now beat captures on c3 Knight captures
on c4 and Queen to d4 now attacking both
nights
so meter plays f5 and the Queen captures
on c4 b6 nice to d4 now preparing to
jump to this powerful e6 square we have
a castle f3 kicking that night Knight to
f6 Bishop to g5 h6 Bishop to h4 g5
Bishop to f2 and now into g7 getting the
King out of this pin well sort of an
x-ray pin but still the king is a
foreign g7 so we have rook after you one
Bishop to d7 Queen to b3 attacking b7
pawn c5 we have D captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now knight c6 check
this kind of forks the king and the
queen so the bishop has to capture the
night we have this captures only 6 and
rook captures any 627 and now hook to d1
attacking this e six form so we have
nice to d5
Bishop to b4 check King to h7 rook rook
d te one rook a to e8 rook captures an
eh rook captures any a truck kept
resonate and Queen captures any eight
and if you look at this position black
is although although blacks position is
a bit drafty and
the black is upon up and with precise
play black could probably probably win
this or or at least holds to a draw but
we have an interesting match laughter he
plays the Queen to b7 trick and now
obviously obviously meter cannot play
King to g8 as the Queen to g7 would be
instant checkmate this Bishop is
guarding g7 so meter place became to g6
Slifer plays Queen to g7 check we have
King to h5 and now h3 and well this King
is a bit uncomfortable but it likes
moving black should do something to
prevent any ideas from white but meter I
decided that this g4 move isn't really
doing anything since black can simply
seem to play King to h4 and then King to
g3 you know there isn't a threat here
really so he plays a queen to e6
but this allows a beautiful combination
by selector as a meter completely missed
it and he indeed does play g4 check but
you'll see you'll see his idea if you
can find the idea then you should
definitely try and pause the video and
see if you can figure this out by
yourself and if you managed congratulate
you as always and if not here is what's
left your head in mind major plays F
captors on g4 we have h captures on g4
and now King to h4 and now the move
selector head in mind it's Queen
captures an 86 with checked a very nice
Queen sacrifice and well looking at the
Queen has to be captured if the king of
the g3 and simply Queen captures the
entire Queen on e6 so Queen captures in
h6 and now a very nice move brush
selector of king - king - h2 and this is
completely winning he cuts off any
squares for this black King to go - and
well the threat of the bishop to f2
checkmate is unstoppable
well you could stop it for one move by
playing 93 but then it will be the same
checkmate every move in the next move so
yeah
a very nice game back our selector he
was a very very strong player and like I
said he he defeated last or a couple of
times and drew drew a lot against
against Emmanuel Alaska and he defeated
a lot of strong players during his time
and yeah that's it I do hope you enjoyed
the game as usual you can check two of
my season two of my previous videos here
and thank you all for watching I will
see you soon
[Music]